It is also important to look at how the component frameworks differ in as far as
their support for variability is concerned.
Recall that one of the key advantages of components and their late
finding is the fact that there's some flexibility provided to their customer.
As far as Java and
CLI are concerned, they use a single virtual machine for all platforms.
Many languages can generate byte codes that target those particular platforms.
COM also supports many languages, but on Microsoft platforms only.
CORBA supports, supports multiple languages, but each of the,
each of the languages must its own IDL binding.
Each platform must also have an object request broker
running on that particular platform.